COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
we help a cloudy developer
get clarity in the tracing
and high instance counts.
Does the forecast
call for sunny skies?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
An old friend of mine recently
launched a new image service
called Partly Cloudy which
provides high resolution
images of clouds for
developers who need to use them
in professional presentations.
After a week of
launching her open beta,
she woke up one morning to
see this little gem waiting
for her in the Google
Cloud developer console.
The blue line in this
graph charts the number
of active App Engine instances
that the application is using.
These numbers are
really high, considering
the application's only
job is to grab an image
and send it to the user.
But the developer of
Partly Cloudy had a hunch.
She was seeing really
high latency numbers
in the trace results
and was assuming
that this was responsible for
the high number of instances.
In some cases,
high response time
can cause new instances
to be spun up.
So after looking at this list
of traces, I had to agree.
This looked like
the obvious problem.
However, when I dug into
the tracing information,
things started to
get really weird.
The latency was being
reported as six seconds,
but the trace information said
that the sum of all RPC calls
was only taking about
180 milliseconds.
Now, while digging in more,
things started to get wacky.
I added some custom tracing
code around the entire response
section, which
showed us that there
was no rogue code executing
and taking up time.
Things were happening
really fast.
The big issue here,
though, was that we
weren't seeing the huge six
second delays that the logs
were showing from before.
In fact, any repo
I tried didn't seem
to exhibit the same slow
performance numbers, even when
submitting the exact
same HTTP request.
The breakthrough
came when I looked
at the logging information
for the slower request.
It was coming from
a mobile device.
This gave me an idea.
What if the connection speed
was causing the trace numbers
to be inflated?
To test this theory out, I
throttled my connection speed
with a few curl commands,
which you can also
do in Chrome Dev Tools, and
got the following timings.
Sadly, still no changes.
When dealing with really
odd discrepancies like this,
it's sometimes good
to take a break.
So we grabbed some tacos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When we came back, we found
that our quizzical error
had gotten even more complex.
The traces, which had
low latency before,
suddenly had a higher
value in the tracing list.
After another 30
minutes, it seemed
that the graph had updated
with these new numbers.
Then I remembered something.
Sitting between user connections
and your App Engine instance
is a series of App
Engine front ends.
These front ends will act as
a liaison between the client
and the given instance.
When the App Engine instance
is done processing a request,
the data is passed back
to the front end, which
stays connected to the
client as long as it
takes to transfer the data.
While this is happening,
the App Engine instance
can be off servicing
other requests.
Now what this means to you is
that regardless of how slow
the client connection
is, it's not
going to impact
your instance count.
Now, it makes sense
then that there
will be a slight delay in the
traces receiving and updating
this information.
There's lots of
complex steps here.
And all that data has to be
gathered and presented properly
to the tracing tool.
More importantly, this means
that Partly Cloudy's instance
count was not a function of
connection speed or weird code
issues.
Turns out, the reason for
the high instance count
was resounding success.
When we flipped over
to the traffic graph,
we saw that over
the past six hours,
people have been using the
Partly Cloudy service really
aggressively.
Partly Cloudy was a
victim of its own success.
But still, the
instances are too high.
And now that we knew that there
wasn't some weird code issue,
we could get to bringing
that number down.
It turns out that Partly
Cloudy's architecture
was really part of the problem.
In their setup, App Engine
will handle the request
from a client, do an
NDB query to the data
store, which contains info
on all the 20,000 images
available.
From there, the
instance will randomly
pick one, fetch the full
image from the GCS bucket,
send it along, back with
its details, to the client.
The solution then
is straightforward.
Let's find a way
to spend less time
having the clients talk to
App Engine and more time
having them ping GCS buckets
directly, which meant
changing the access pattern.
When the client fetches
an image from GAE,
append the next 10 images ID as
an extra header in the field.
The client will then fetch
the next 10 images directly
from GCS rather than needing
to go through GAE for it.
When we're out of pre-fetched
images, go back to the server
and grab the next batch.
When we flipped
over to this code,
the results were
better than expected.
An eight-hour run saw
instance count drop
from about 16 instances
on average to about 1.5.
See, that's the trick with
performance improvements.
You have to eliminate all the
possibilities before really
understanding the problem.
And to learn more about
all the possible ways
that perf can go
sideways, check out
the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas videos.
And remember, when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]